i mean i'm always like aware of the fact
that like we always as humans and the
scientists think that we figured out
99 and we're working on that first one
and we got to keep reminding ourselves
it's hard to do like we figured out like
not even one percent like where
we know nothing yeah and so like i can't
i can speculate
i might sound like a fool but like what
are drugs even the concept of drugs like
10 year 50 years 100 years a thousand
years if we if we're
surviving like
you know molecules that go to a specific
area
of the brain in combination with
technology in combination with the
magnetic stimulation
in combination with the you know like
targeted pharmacology of like oh
like this subset of serotonin 2a
receptors in the colostrum
you know at this time in this particular
sequence in combination with this other
thing
like this baseball cap you wear that
like has
you know you know has has one of the is
doing some of these things we can only
do with these like giant like pieces of
equipment now like
where it's going to go is going to be
endless and it becomes easy to
you know combine within virtual reality
where the virtuality is going to move
from being something out here
to being more in there and then we're
getting like we talked about before
we're already in a virtual reality in
terms of human
perception and and cognition models of
the
of the universe being all
representations and
you know sort of you know color not
existing and just you know our
representations of
em um wavelengths etc etc you know sound
being vibrations and all of this and so
as the the external vr and the internal
vr
come closer to each other like this is
what i think about in terms of the
future of drugs
like all of this stuff sort of combines
and
and like where that goes is just
it's it's unthinkable like we we're
probably gonna
you know again i might sound like a fool
and this may not happen but i think it's
possible
you know to go completely offline like
where most of people's experiences may
be
going into these internal worlds
and i mean maybe you through through
some
through a combination of these
techniques you create experiences where
someone could live a thousand years
in terms of maybe they're living a
regular lifespan but in over the next
two seconds you're living a thousand
years worth of experience
inside inside your mind through yeah
through this manipulation of the
like is that possible like just based
on on like first principles i suppose
yes i think so yeah like give us another
50 000 500 like who knows but
like how could it not go there
you